if you want to hear the details about
carrie's life that weren't included in
the movies then stick around to the end
of this video this video is sponsored by
audible
i've covered a lot of characters in
stephen king's universe of stories here
on the show
so in this week's episode i'm taking it
back to the one that started it all
welcome to horror history my name is
professor sissy's world and in today's
lesson i'm joined by my ta
the amagi as we cover the entire life of
carrie white kerry was created by the
then rookie author as a sort of
combination of two girls from his
childhood
the first was in grade school with king
and she was made fun of by some of the
other classmates for wearing the same
clothes to school every day
the other lived in his neighborhood with
her mother and one time the mother hired
him to move some furniture and when he
went inside he realized that they're
crazy religious
neither of these girls would live to
read carrie though one was personally
responsible while the other one had
problems with seizures their fates may
tie in to what ends up happening in
kerry but before we can get there i'm
going to take it all the way back to the
conception of carrie white
[Music]
margaret brigham and ralph white were
married on march 23 1962
and that same year they first engage in
what margaret would refer to as a sinful
act so she made her husband promise
never to do it again she fell down one
day and lost the baby and she assumed
that this was their punishment for their
sins that god did not want her to have
the baby
one night ralph started giving her that
look again i'm not gonna do it right
here on camera because i don't wanna be
a father but
she sent him away and when he came back
she smelled the scent of roadhouse
whiskey on his breath
nine months later on september 21 1963
she gave birth to carrietta and white
margaret's mental state deteriorated
throughout the pregnancy and she planned
to kill carrie with a knife upon birth
because she believed her daughter would
be a carrier of the devil but when it
came time she could not bring herself to
do it instead using the knife to cut the
umbilical cord she would try again three
years later in 1966. here's what went
down
mrs white had long feuded with her
neighbors the horn family because their
daughter estelle would sometimes
sunbathe in the backyard which was
within margaret's line of sight
mrs horan found this complaint
ridiculous and in retaliation bought a
stella a new bikini and
encouraged her to use it whenever she
liked so three-year-old carrie wandered
over to a sunbathing estelle one day and
posed the question
i'm sorry that was too easy not to do
when estella explained the concepts of
breasts to her carrie wished that she
could get them too
because her mother had taught her that
good girls don't get them as part of her
wacko religious beliefs estelle tried to
explain the truth to carrie but not
before margaret came out and started
screaming at her to the point that
estelle started to get into it with
margaret mrs
white was clawing at herself grinning
and drooling and what she saw is
punishing herself to make up for what
carrie had seen
this kind of self-destructive behavior
warped carrie's mind from a very young
age and caused her to have an imbalance
in her brain as she grew older she drags
carrie into the house and forces her
daughter to go into the closet to pray
which carey strongly disliked because
the religious imagery scared her so she
did what any kid would do
and threw a fit however carrie white was
not like any other kid she was born with
a special gene that researchers would
later refer to as the tk gene
tk was an acronym for telekinesis the
ability to move
objects at a distance via the use of
mental power both of carrie's parents
had this gene but it was recessive in
her mother so it only showed up in cary
carrie's grandmother was also supposedly
a fire starter an ability that would be
explored more in another stephen king
novel but it's not known if the gene for
this is the same as the gene for tk
the neighbor estelle heard carrie's
screams emanating from inside the house
this is what set carries telekinesis off
it started when a huge chunk of ice was
pulled down and thumped against the
white's roof then it was several chunks
of ice and keep in mind this is
happening in the middle of august
the ice stopped and margaret started
screaming again that's when the white's
kitchen table went crashing out the
window a small sample of the magnitude
of kerry's power she brought down a rain
of stones upon the house
neighbors watched as they burst through
roof shingles punching holes through the
ceiling the stones consisted of chunks
of granite which only came down on the
white's property the stones that didn't
hit the house left small craters in the
backyard the event became known by the
neighborhood as the reign of stones and
i think it's no mistake that it was
triggered by carrie finding out about
the pubescent development of breasts and
her mother punishing her for it carrie's
powers would be fully unleashed when she
herself reaches the age of her budding
adulthood so there seems to be a
comparison going on between sexual
awakening and telekinetic awakening
it wouldn't be the last time that
stephen king would make a similar
comparison as you know if you've seen my
horror history on beverly marsh from it
it seems that carrie started going to
public school in first grade this may
have coincided with her mom getting a
job at the blue ribbon laundry when the
insurance money from ralph's death had
run out carrie is described as a chunky
girl with pimples none of the movies
hold true to this description
probably because her beauty is supposed
to blossom by the time of the prom
and you can do that in a book but in a
movie your best bet is just to hide her
looks until the prom scene comes around
carrie did not get along well in school
though and quickly became a social
outcast this was most likely due to her
psycho mother and the fact that she was
forbidden from taking part in most
social activities she also had a few
particularly nasty classmates like
christine hargensen and helen shires
in grade school carrie went to a
christian youth camp where they would
short sheet her bed
hide her underwear and put a snake in
her shoe
and pass around a love letter addressed
to flash bobby pickets that they'd found
in carrie's possession
if you're wondering who flash bobby
pickett is i don't know where the name
flash comes from that seems to be
exclusive to carrie but bobby pickett is
the guy who wrote the monster mash
and if you're wondering what the monster
mash is it was a graveyard smash
and if you're wondering how it became a
graveyard smash it caught on in a flash
okay maybe that's where flash comes from
carrie had to be brought home from camp
a week early on her first day of grammar
school she was laughed at for praying at
lunch
as you can probably imagine the torture
from the other kids and the abuse from
her devil paranoid mother would continue
as carrie moved on to the next layer of
hell commonly known
as middle school
[Music]
there is a lot you can learn here on
horror history but if you really want
the full stephen king experience you
gotta check out the novel there are so
many characters interviews and snippets
from articles within the world of carrie
that you're missing out on if you don't
the best way to enjoy stephen king's
carry is with audible the audiobook is
narrated by [ __ ] spacek the actress who
plays carrie white in the original movie
how cool is that
audible is a great option for that
person you care about or for yourself
now is the best time to do it with a
special offer of 53
off your first three months access an
unbeatable selection of audiobooks
including bestsellers mysteries
thrillers and of course
horror you can choose three titles every
month one audiobook and two exclusive
audible originals that you can't hear
anywhere else listen on any device
anytime anywhere with the audible app
it's great while commuting at the gym
or during your holiday travels with
audible you'll also enjoy easy audiobook
exchanges and your own audiobook library
you keep
forever even if you cancel right now for
a limited time you can get three months
of audible for just 6.95 per month
that's more than half off the regular
price
give yourself the gift of listening for
more go to audible.comworld
one of the few activities that carrie
white was allowed to partake in were
these biking trips
actually it doesn't seem that she really
wanted to go but maybe it was a church
activity or something in school a boy
named billy preston put peanut butter in
her hair now according to rhett and link
he was actually doing her a favor but
the deep-seated rage continued to build
inside of her people would pinch her
stick out legs to trip her in class
knock books from her desk and tuck
obscene messages into her bag
in high school chris hargensen prank
called her asking if she knew how to
spell pig poop
and then spelling k-a-r-r-i-e which i
have to say is not even that good of a
prank call but
i guess this was before iconic
masterpieces like arnold schwarzenegger
prank calls travel agency and keeps
asking about the guy they lobotomized
may i have your email address please
yeah what do you mean we
i i in order to book this um may i have
your email address please
what about the guy you lobotomized did
he get the refund good guy
i can't carry would have to endure cruel
punishments that she didn't deserve like
being locked in the closet for an entire
day after stealing a 49-cent plastic
ring and another time when her mom found
a picture of flash bobby pickett under
her pillow
guess she really likes the monster mash
at one point in seventh grade she seemed
to try to call out for help when she
turned in the following as a poetry
assignment in english class
jesus watches from the wall but his face
is cold as stone
if he loves me as she tells me why do i
feel so all alone
this is a piece about her time being
locked inside the closet by her mother
and while the instructor did find that
it seemed to cry out to him he did not
pursue the topic any
further but perhaps the biggest moment
came during carrie's senior year of high
school harry was the last to shower
after gym class in an attempt to avoid
the other girls when she got her period
like the reign of stones when she was
three it was her mother's neglect to
give her a proper education due to mrs
white's unsound levels of piousness that
once again caused the issue carrie
believed that she was bleeding to death
because she'd never learned what a
period is
her mom didn't teach her and she didn't
have any friends to learn from
she staggered to the other girls who
were finishing up getting changed and
they found
it hilarious they basically saw this as
the equivalent of arnold calling the
travel agency
i just didn't need an email address so i
can email you your confirmation
okay two three
five seven okay i'm sorry i'm done
i'm done now okay so the whole gym class
started chanting
period and throwing tampons at her and
in her confusion carrie collapsed in the
corner the gym teacher mr jardin came in
to see what the problem was and ended up
slapping carrie in the face to try to
bring her to her senses
a light bulb explodes overhead and this
ties carrie's outburst of anger to her
telekinetic power
once ms desjardins realized that carrie
didn't know what a period was
she tries to comfort her and get the
other girls away she ended up having to
explain the concept of menstruation
before getting carrie cleaned up and
taking her to the office of the
assistant principal mr morton where he
files an accident form and decides to
give carrie the rest of the day off mr
morton repeatedly calls her cassie
instead of carrie one too many times and
she snaps at him that's not my
name she screamed suddenly mr morton
recoiled and ms desjardin jumped as if
struck from behind
the heavy ceramic ashtray on morton's
desk it was rodan's thinker with his
head turned into a receptacle for
cigarette butts
suddenly toppled to the rug as if to
take cover from the force of her scream
butts and flakes of morton's pipe
tobacco scattered on the pale green
nylon rug
like the light bulb this is another
example of the fervor of her telekinesis
matching the anger pent up inside of her
she had a lot of anger on hand to dish
out pretty much at will which we see
shortly after she walked home
at this point carrie is fed up with
having endured 17 years of harassment
there's only so much that a person can
take so it's understandable that her
thoughts would turn dark but what makes
this scary is what happens next
a five-year-old boy riding his bike on
the street makes fun of her and calls
her creepy carry
creepy carry creepy carry so that little
[ __ ] gets aeriated right off that bike
kerry would also try to use her tk to
break a window on the way home but she's
only able to make it wobble showing that
she's yet to fully master the ability
she still has to practice more before
being able to fully channel her rage at
will but later that afternoon she was
able to crack her mirror while
self-loathing about her own reflection
her mother came home after getting a
call from the school carrie notices the
fear in her mother's eyes
there are a few examples in the book
where margaret seems to be able to sense
carrie's rising power but it's likely
that she perceived it as the devil
inside of her daughter waking up
mrs white struck her and then forced her
head into the altar they had in the
living room commanding her to pray for
her sins to which she insisted that she
had not sinned
this was a turning point for carrie
because up until now she had no reason
to believe her mother's lies she was
also about to graduate high school and
didn't want to live under the harmful
hand of her mother forever and that's
why i think she chooses this occasion
to fight back
as margaret tried to pull her daughter
away into the closet carrie refused to
go quietly
raising her voice and using profanity
against her again the fear is evidence
in margaret's eyes carrie threatens to
make the stones come again
remembering the outburst that had
occurred when she was three and her mom
calls her the spawn of the devil before
dragging her and locking her in the
closet
this was probably the most she'd ever
fought back against her mom but i think
that's because of her rising fear the
punishment is not as severe as carrie
might have thought
carrie even thinks that her mama may
have been afraid that she'd blow the
closet door right off of its hinges if
she was kept in for too long
carrie took a little bit of time off of
school and used it to further hone her
telekinetic abilities she would practice
at home in her room by picking up the
foot of her bed and placing it back down
her heart pounded with excitement as she
did so and at night she would dream of
sending stones after her mom
and the kids that bullied her at school
when she goes back to school she keeps
to herself even more than usual hoping
to avoid being the subject of laughter
and gossip about what happened but that
thursday after her fifth period study
hall she received a surprise visit from
a boy she was attracted to
tommy ross tommy was the boyfriend of
susan snell one of the girls who had
made fun of her in the locker room but
who was not otherwise
normally a bad person tommy ended up
inviting her to be his dates to the
spring ball
this is the moment that i've been hyping
up in every horror history to date so
pay attention
what happens next is kind of interesting
it's not entirely clear if carrie is
able to shine yet
shining is an ability in stephen king's
writing allowing people most often kids
to read minds
she's able to do it by the end of the
story though her first instinct is that
tommy is tricking her
that he's only inviting her to humiliate
her somehow if she'd been able to shine
she'd know that his invitation was
genuine
but perhaps she did shine and she saw
that tommy didn't want to ask carrie to
the prom which is also true because he
was only doing it to please sue who felt
bad about the locker room incident for
these reasons carrie rejects him at
first but he is persistent about it and
she worries that she's going to make him
late for his next class and she accepts
that week she goes into town and buys
some fabric to make herself a dress
sewing was one of the few hobbies her
mom allowed her to have so she was quite
familiar with the chamberlain
woolsworths where she bought her
material she had not yet broken the news
to her mother which caused her a great
deal of anxiety and stress which of
course translated to telekinetic energy
on saturday night carrie prepares
herself to tell her mother of the prom
invite knowing that she is unlikely to
approve
and she doesn't
okay the tea was only lukewarm but you
get the idea as expected margaret orders
her to go to the closet but carrie
refuses looking to make a statement they
get into a huge argument because
margaret sees this as the next step
towards a path to the devil
after the blood comes the boys like
sniffing dogs
running and slaving and trying to find
out where that smell comes from
where the smell is there's another way
they take in their gut i see it all
right
well you're not going carrie tells her
that she's tired of being made fun of
and wants to start fitting in with her
classmates she wants to live her own
life not be stuck living her mother's
her mom calls her a witch and i see that
as another important step towards
carrie's breakdown
even though her mother did not treat her
properly she was still her mother and
carrie knew no better than to look to
and love her
not to mention that she was one of the
only people carrie could actually talk
to
if her mother started to oppose her she
would have nobody to go to the next time
she is humiliated and be forced to turn
down a darker path
and that day would soon come margaret
retreated upstairs and began whispering
exorcism prayers
on may 26th the day before the prom
kerry went to go talk to tommy one more
time before the big event she waited
outside one of his classes so she could
let him know that she'd have to be in by
11 30 pm as not to upset her mother more
than she already had
tommy thoughtfully suggested that after
the dance they go to the kelly fruits to
get a root beer and a burger he figured
it would be a good place to unwind since
many of the other kids would be going to
parties in other cities and it would
most likely be empty
see would later comment on the exchange
in her book this is the girl that they
keep calling a monster i want you to
keep that firmly in mind the girl who
could be satisfied with a hamburger and
a dime root beer after her only school
dance so her mama wouldn't be worried
the day that carrie would first put on
the dress would soon come it was may 27
1969 as kerry examined herself in it the
door swings open to reveal her mother
holding a bible
right i might have known it would be red
the red dress is symbolic of everything
that this night stands for prom night is
the night that high school students
dress up like adults practice the
rituals of courtship and in most cases
do
adult things afterwards like paying
taxes
okay now we're talking about sex the red
dress is a perfect metaphor for that
because it was the red blood of kerry's
first period that made her transition
into adulthood evidence and from her
mother's point of view as i pointed out
in my things you missed episode on the
1976 movie
red is also the color of the devil
carrie did not know if her powers came
from satan or if they were a gift from
the lord but she was beginning not to
care and would use her powers against
her mom in order to attend the prom if
necessary margaret asked her to burn the
dress
and pray for forgiveness with her which
of course angers carrie ironically the
dress would be one of the few things at
the prom to not burn carrie uses her
mind to swing the door shut on her
mother who goes down to go to work that
night mrs white spends at least two
hours praying in their home chapel so
carrie is forced to pin the corsage to
the shoulder of her dress herself an
image that is indicative of how she was
now truly alone with nobody to turn to
as it got later carrie got more nervous
thoughts creep into her head about tommy
standing her up and she actually starts
to think that this would be for the best
there would only be one more month of
high school so the humiliation wouldn't
last all that long but then she thinks
about being stuck with her mother
forever about going over to the 86 year
old mrs garrison's house and watching
game shows and soap operas rather than
starting her own life
carrie is restlessly picking up objects
with her mind and putting them back down
on the ground when she hears tommy's car
approach
her mother's chanting stops as she hears
the buzzer
when carrie answers the door neither one
of them says a word at first
until she says do you like me and he
replies with you look beautiful
with that the two set off together not
knowing that this would be the final
evening of their lives
when tommy ross pulled into the parking
lot he asked her if she was nervous and
she said yes but i think the next scene
does a far better job of communicating
how nervous she actually was
everyone stopped to look at tommy and
carrie as they entered the prom creating
a momentary silence that was only broken
by tommy's buddy george dawson coming up
and throwing a mock insult about his
appearance
dawson lurched forward with his fists up
and for a moment kerry felt stark terror
in her keyed up state she came within an
ace of picking george up and throwing
him across the lobby
then she realized it was an old game
often played well loved carrie was
obviously very on edge so george's date
frida tries to calm her down by joking
that she'll dance with carrie if tommy
and george kill each other she also asks
carrie about her dress and is very
impressed that kerry made it herself
as the four of them go into the dance
together george is doing flash bobby
picket impressions what is it with this
flash bobby picket it's like the third
time he's come up
when they entered carrie found the dance
to be glamorous and there's a line where
she specifically views
the long flowing dresses on the dance
floor to be like wraiths maybe that's a
foreshadowing of all their impending
deaths
as carrie tommy george and frida admire
the mural carrie knew she'd remember the
moment forever but perhaps what she did
not know was that forever would only be
a few more hours
george takes frida onto the dance floor
and tommy and carrie decide to sit down
one of the bullies a girl named norma
takes them to their table asking about
carrie's dress as she does so
norma comments on how different carrie
looks the one time in her life that she
actually fits in for a short while but
carrie notices something of a secretive
look on norma's face and that makes
carrie nervous
and for a good reason norma was part of
a conspiracy created by chris
harkinson's clique of girls known as the
mortimer snerds who planned to humiliate
carrie by getting her elected as prom
queen where hargensen would pull the
cord to have a bucket of pig's blood
dumped all over carrie
tommy asked carrie to dance but she told
him she just wanted to sit for a while
in reality she had no idea how to dance
and wanted to avoid the embarrassment
she asked tommy to light the candles at
their table which may be another
foreshadowing this time about how the
night would end in flames
at 9 00 pm that evening tommy asked
harry to dance for a third time
and she finally admitted that she did
not know how they end up waiting for a
slower song and that's a scene in most
if not all of the movie adaptations but
what the movies fail to explain is that
the dancing isn't the only thing that
makes carrie uncomfortable she's also
bothered by the idea of going out there
to rock and roll music which is
something that carrie's mother has
conditioned her to see as sinful and if
that's true i'm going straight to the
bottom layer of hell
i probably am anyways let's be real they
go around to talk to some of the other
tables and carrie sees people bringing
out the king and queen thrones and she
thinks that they're beautiful and
imagines her and tommy winning the crown
maybe this was just her imagination
running wild because she's obviously not
going to be a popular choice without
intervention but maybe this was actually
her shining and seeing a little glimpse
of the future where they're victorious
when they get back to the table tommy
goes to get her a little bit of punch
and kerry sees the gym teacher mrs
jardin who tells her about her own
experience at the prom how she had been
taller than her dates how the corsage he
had given her and clashed with her gown
and how the broken tailpipe on the car
made a horrible noise
what's up guys
[Music]
but that she still found it to be a
magical night i only bring this up
because they've changed the story in
literally every adaptation
i had a date with the captain of the
basketball team he was
six feet seven inches tall anyway we
went in his pickup truck
which of course broke down and we had to
get out and walk the last half mile to
the prime
my date brought a toy gun so he could
pose like james bond for the picture
oh he sounds like fun yeah
they arrested him i didn't have anybody
to dance with
spent the entire night alone until my
father picked me up
anyway carrie tells mr jardin that she
couldn't quite tell her how the prom
made her feel
tommy comes back with the punch and
carrie thinks that the encounter with mr
jardin was her way of saying she's sorry
for everything that happened in the
locker room
at 9 30 the class president vic mooney
who would be one of the few survivors of
the black prom announces the opening of
the ballots for prom king and queen
kerry is surprised to see her and
tommy's name on the ballot which tommy
explains as the school voting for single
candidates and their dates getting
shanghaied into it
tommy suggests that they vote for
themselves and carry giggles when she
does so she's surprised at the sound of
her own laughter which is one of those
things where if you think about it it's
incredibly sad because she's never had
friends and so she's never really
laughed
even in her entire life and i'm not
gonna play the clip don't worry i'm not
gonna play the clip
but it was before this video so there
were less reasons to laugh in the world
while filling out the ballot she
accidentally hurts herself as the pencil
breaks in her hand
like the small candles i think the small
amount of blood that's drawn is a tiny
preview of the splashdown that would
soon come
the honors society collects the ballots
and the students watch as two piles
stack up higher than any of the others
and eventually it has announced that
ewen high school has had its first ever
tie
63 votes for frank grier and jessica
mclean and 63 votes for tommy ross and
carrie white
they decide to hold a runoff ballot to
determine the winner this time
kerry begged tommy not to vote for them
perhaps sensing that something was going
to go wrong
but tommy had promised sue to try to
give carrie the best night possible so
he elects to try to vote her in
anyways it was 1007 pm when the
secondary ballots were collected and
again
it looked like it was going to be close
tommy and carrie end up winning by just
one vote had tommy listened to carrie
and held back his vote
perhaps the whole disaster could have
been avoided okay so i was actually
curious about what would happen if it
was a tie again
and i looked it up and found some random
school in ohio that had their rules
posted online they said they'd also
institute a second vote if the initial
poll is tied and then if that one is
tied there can be multiple winners
though i feel like hargenson still
probably would have dumped the blood
just to get revenge on kerry for
getting her in trouble at gym class
ushers would appear and lead carrie and
tommy to their thrones while the band
played the school song
they took their place in front of the
crowd and everything had fallen into
place for christine hargensen and
although she hesitates at first she
pulls the cord which turns through the
pulley and attaches to the two buckets
of blood sitting on the rafters above
the prom king and queen thrones
after the massive red splash came down
carrie looked like she'd been dipped in
red paint
for a moment the gymnasium was
completely silent the two buckets
clinged together and one of them came
down and hit tommy in the head
and the winner by split decision is
the bucket
someone started to laugh at the noise
that the bucket made when it knocked out
tommy but it wasn't until carrie opened
her eyes back up the only part of her
that was not red that everyone started
to crack up
but they'd soon find out that kerry
white would be the one to have the last
laugh
ms desjardins ran up to her aid and
although she was not laughing on the
surface carrie could hear the giggling
reverberate through the gym teacher's
head so she uses her tk to push her
aside where she goes crashing into the
wall
carrie ran through the crowd where
someone tripped her she crawled away and
ran out of the gym out of the lobby down
the stairs and outside of the school
with a laughter behind her now she got
her feet tangled and fell into the grass
the whole thing had only been about two
minutes she was filled with tears and
her first instinct was to return home to
her mother in shame
and had mrs white treated her daughter
better that may have been the end of
it but then again if that had been the
case probably none of this would have
happened carrie thinks about the closet
and about how long she would be locked
in at this time
about what her mother would do to her
and that's what made her snap
just as she did to little tommy irpter
on the bicycle carrie decided to use her
powers for evil
she ditches her shoes and walks barefoot
back to the lobby and all at once
slams the doors shut the screams she
heard from inside were described as
being like sweet soul music to her the
panicked crowd stampedes towards the
doors where carrie stares at them back
through the window people battered
against the doors which did not budge
some went out the back fire doors and
carrie allowed them to escape thinking
that she'll have time to pick them off
later she uses her minds to turn on the
overhead sprinklers and when everyone
was soaking wet carrie could not hear
them crying so she decided that the
sprinklers were not enough
she pulled out the power cables into the
puddles of water that now covered the
gym floor causing a huge flash of light
and the electrocution of one of the
performers holding a microphone stand
after another flash of light his shirt
had caught fire and one of the main
power
switches backstage exploded light cables
arrived in the air and one of them came
down into the water causing yet another
violent flash
carrie went back down the stairs all
while holding the main doors closed with
her mind with the entire gym on fire now
she made her way onto the streets the
town fire whistle sounded and i think
that was what caused her momentarily to
lose hold of the doors but she quickly
regained it and slammed them back shut
catching someone's fingers inside as she
did so now the movies always seem to
under-appreciate the damage that carrie
did to the town after leaving the high
school for the last time
she headed into town and had the
realization that the fire department may
put out her creation
so she telekinetically twisted the fire
hydrant lug nuts perhaps the most
mentally draining use of her power yet
based on how it is described she's able
to open the valves and water bursts
everywhere
carrie's heartbeat speeds up as she
realizes she's essentially one
the gushing water is a symbol that
connects the shower scene where carrie
was hurt and humiliated to the rampage
scene where carrie pays that back to the
entire town of chamberlain she goes to
the grass plaza where she's seen trying
to rub her hands clean on the side of
her dress and she opens a few more fire
hydrants before heading up to the gas
station teddy's amico
when she got there just before 11
o'clock she removed all of the nozzles
and made them pour gas onto the ground
until someone unknowingly dropped a
cigarette this caused a massive oil
tank explosion shortly after at 11 12 pm
kerry had the entirety of main street in
flames her next target was the other gas
station in town tony sitka which
exploded at 11 15. the blast was so big
that it temporarily lit up all of summer
street in what looked like daylight
this was followed by another secondary
explosion her progress was slowed a
little bit but not halted when she
stepped onto a broken bottle on the
street this is a small reminder that she
is human despite her terrifying powers
and that she too could be hurt
just like anyone else something that
would soon come into play she arrives at
her next destination at 1206 am on the
morning of the 28th where she's able to
use her minds to locate and open the gas
main underneath jackson streets
shortly after she's seen going inside
the carlin street church this is purely
speculation but i think she hoped she'd
find the answer to one of the last
questions that had eluded her to this
point was she really an agent of the
devil or were her powers a gift from god
when she received no answer she used a
whirlwind of psychic energy to destroy
the inside of the church
she emerged from there at 12 11 and
telekinetically swings the door shut
behind her she also took out power
transformers and dangled the live wires
onto the streets one of these cables
even reached a nearby house and set that
on fire as well
and remember that gas valve that she
opened on jackson street well at 12 17
an ambulance attendant pitched a
cigarette butt out the window and set
that ablaze too
see if the regular dangers of smoking
were not enough to deter you take
chamberlain maine in 1979 as an example
damage could have been basically cut in
half if people weren't lighting up
and this guy was an ambulance attendant
he's literally supposed to keep people
healthy why does he even have a
cigarette
it was not long after that when prom
turned into homecoming because carrie
found herself back at the door of the
small house on carlin street
the lights were entirely shut off when
she arrived the only illumination coming
from the raging fires approaching from
the town
objects fell from the walls as she got
close and when she arrived she blew all
the living room windows outward and
slammed the kitchen door kerry is
described to this point to have
completely lost touch with her humanity
but being back in the presence of her
mother may have brought her back down to
earth a little bit
either that or she was starting to
realize the severity of what she had
done
because when she stepped into the house
she was trembling and whispering out for
her mama her dress was in tatters
like the poem she handed in back in
seventh grade her return home had a
deeper meaning than what was on the
surface but the mother and daughter were
so mentally unhinged at that point that
there was only one inevitable
[Applause]
[Music]
outcome
when the two confront each other
margaret hides the kitchen knife that
she's spent the last several hours
sharpening
yeah calm down margaret she tells the
story of carrie's conception in the
pregnancy how she planned to slay the
devil inside her when carrie was born
which drives her crazy she channels her
telekinetic anger into the plates in the
kitchen which they both hear exploding
carrie was unable to follow through with
what she planned to do to her mother at
first and begged for help
i think many people would argue that
carrie was not a monster but rather a
victim of her own circumstances
and if there's any evidence of that this
part is probably an example
margaret asked her to pray with her one
more time but when kerry bowies her head
margaret brings the knife down over her
terry seems to sense this at the last
moment and mentally moves the trajectory
of the knife
the way that carrie kills her mom has
got to be one of the coolest uses of
telekinesis that i've seen anywhere
she tells her i'm gonna give you a
present mama and then she looks into her
chest and slowly brings her mother's
beating heart to a stop
i just think that's so metal because
there's basically nothing you can do to
defend yourself against that
kerry could not stick around long though
because the flames from the fires in
town had spread as close as next door
and the roof which she had already
destroyed one time 14 years ago with the
stones was starting to ignite
carrie slipped out the back door she
crosses through backyards and when she
can no longer walk she crawls up an
embankment
not stopping until 1 15 am when she
arrived at a roadhouse known as the
cavalier
a bunch of people were going to the
cavalier after it's even suggested in
the text that this could be the same
roadhouse where ralph white had stopped
the night that carrie was conceived and
she'd crawled all of this way to come
destroy it but her main motive most
likely had more to do with who was at
the cavalier chris hargensen and her
boyfriend billy nolan who had helped set
up the buckets of blood they had just
heard about the disaster and gotten into
the car to flee when billy turns on the
headlights chris screams because carrie
white is standing there with a crazed
look on her face
instinctively billy just floors it and
as they approach they hear the words
carrie
carrie carrie being chanted in their
heads over and over it seems that when
carrie's sanity snapped
so too did her ability to keep her shine
inside of her own head most of what we
know about a rampage through the town
obviously doesn't come from carrie
firsthand but those who encountered her
and lived to tell the tale could hear
her thoughts as if she were no longer a
radio but now a radio station it's never
spelled out for us how exactly this
works in the book but there is one point
where sue seems to believe that the zone
of carrie's influence was shrinking as
she was starting to die
if the unscrewing of the fire hydrants
wasn't carrie's most impressive feat
then what would come next
definitely is she spun the car around in
a half circle and sent it flying into
the cavalier billy is thrown through the
windshield and chris crumbles against
the dashboard before the vehicle
explodes that seemed to take up the rest
of carrie's remaining energy she laid on
her side
panting trying to drag herself across
the parking lot she felt that nothing
else would matter as long as she could
turn herself over and see the stars one
last time before she died but she did
not even have the strength to do that
the last person carrie white ever
encounters is sue snell the one girl who
tried to give carrie that one good high
school experience at the prom the one
person who actually had her best
interests in mind
sue turned her on her back her final
wish fulfilled and carrie in a moan
asks who's there when she finds out that
it's sue carrie accuses her of being in
on the trick to which sue asks her to
look inside her and see the truth carrie
does so scanning the library of sue's
mind the concept of a metaphysical
library or warehouse of memories is
consistent with some of king's later
writings like dreamcatcher and dr sleep
kerry searches through all of sue's
thoughts and memories but finds no
evidence of a plan to sabotage her at
the prom
with that last little piece of mind
carrie pulls back out of sue's head but
in what i can only imagine is some kind
of telekinetic equivalent of newton's
third law
sue gets sucked into carrie's mind
against her will and perceives her final
thoughts she hears carrie crying for her
mother her last conscious thought
is mama i'm sorry where
before fading out into the black carrier
white's official time of death is
recorded at may 28
1979 at 2 am carrie was one of king's
most misunderstood characters if you
read the book you get a better
understanding of how carrie was just a
normal girl but she's pushed into being
an outcast by everyone around her and
the idea of her telekinesis and
mind-reading abilities that seemingly
nobody else has is a metaphor for her
forced separation from the rest of
society the concept would become a
staple of the author's work but stephen
king has actually gone on records saying
that brian de palma's 1976 movie
adaptation of kerry is the superior
version of the story de palma brings in
many more concepts themes and motifs in
his interpretation of the tragic tale so
we decided to do a second video over on
amagi's channel analyzing the entire
life of carrie white in the movie and if
you like horror history definitely go
subscribe to his channel he covers the
lives of many other of your favorite
characters including those outside the
horror genre remember to ring that death
bell for notifications and i'll see you
in the second video
assuming we both survive
you